[Música]
una zona rural humilde al sur de Quito
en una de estas casas una joven
prácticamente ya no sale de su casa
[Música]
afectada por lo que vivió Y por miedo a
ser reconocida Clara nos autoriza a
filmar solo una parte de su cara sin que
sea posible identificar en donde vive
con 16 años está procesada por aborto
para preparar su audiencia Anabel a su
abogada vino a ver a su familia mi hija
le dolía el le dolía el viento Entonces
yo le dije que teníamos que llevarle al
hospital porque yo no sabía qué hacer
con ella
Entonces cuando En eso yo ya llegué al
hospital y me dijeron que era un aborto
que un aborto provocado pero ella decía
no puede ser
entonces en eso hasta de un policía ahí
y este policía se acerque le pregunta al
doctor doctor que está pasando con la
señorita y le dice sabe que es un aborto
que entonces dice Y esto y esto se va a
preso
no podía
sentirme bien al tener
los policías cerca de mí y también ya el
momento que ya dijeron que tenía que ir
detenida así fue como
como con miedo
y yo me puse de rodillas donde los le
dije que por favor no le mande empresa a
mi amiga tengo miedo de tener algún
proceso legal más complicado que pueda
tener algo más que me pueda privarme de
mi libertad Por decirlo así Creo que
podríamos lograrlo la ventaja de esos
que vas a salir como inocente sin
importar que Clara haya tomado o no
misoprostol una pastilla contra los
dolores de estómago a menuda usada para
abortar Ana encontró una estrategia de
defensa alegará un embarazo falso a
pesar de la fecundación no se habría
formado ningún embrión una anomalía que
no es inusual pero en vista de lo que ha
pasado su madre no se siente segura el
dolor como madre Esa fue
que no es fácil olvidarse es todo lo que
yo viví con mi hijo
fue lo más horrible En este hospital
a lo único que podría decirles que me
perdone por haber tenido esa acción
te sientes culpable
sí
según su abogada por ser menor de edad
Clara enfrenta una condena de Máximo dos
meses de cárcel o de servicio
comunitario en Ecuador pequeño país de
17 millones de habitantes el aborto
Sigue estando prohibido
[Música]
cada año cientos de mujeres son
penalizadas por haber aportado las que
tienen los medios interrumpen su
embarazo en clínicas privadas sin tener
problemas pero las mujeres con menos
recursos a veces están en la mira de la
justicia o no tienen otra opción más que
tener su bebé
[Música]
en un país tan conservadores difíciles
escapar a la presión social de la
maternidad
[Música]
a 50 kilómetros de allí en Quito
organizaciones antiobortos recorren los
barrios populares hoy un pequeño camión
acaba de llegar delante de una iglesia
dentro las mujeres pueden hacerse una
ecografía gratis
el piecito mira
[Música]
Ahí está
Le oyes
Amparo Medina no es ni médica ni
ginecóloga es anti aborto
le harías algo de daño a este bebé
no verdad no
eres inocente Mira chiquito Mira mira
mira mira mira mira qué es esto a ver
la cabecita muy bien
afuera en medio de la calle el examen de
la joven es transmitido en directo este
grupo provida como se hace Llamar está
en campaña hacen todo lo posible para
que las mujeres no interrumpan su
embarazo como en el caso de esta joven
sin trabajo embarazada de su tercer bebé
lo que vamos a hacer ahorita es te voy a
mandar la primera muda del bebé la
primera ropita del bebé Sí ahora vamos
también a inscribirte ya para que
empieces a recibir las despensas en la
oficina una vez al mes puedes recoger la
ropa la despensa esta niña no te dijo
que había avanzado
pero no llegó a concretar también por su
situación económica no Solo lo pensó no
tomo pastillas no tomo absolutamente
nada
aquí abortar en una clínica privada
cuesta al menos 400 dólares casi el
equivalente al salario mínimo
el objetivo fundamental es el que la
gente comprenda que dentro del vientre
de una madre embarazada hay un niño que
no es un tumor que no es un cúmulo de
células entonces que la gente tenga
conciencia de quién de quién es el niño
que se va a abortar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el padre pintó un dibujo muy bien el
hijo los dolores
ya que estoy yo
Y aquí estoy yo soy el dibujo perfecto
de Dios Otra vez
el dibujo perfecto de Dios amor un
discurso y una ideología que comparte
toda una parte de la población 80% de la
cual es católica Incluso en los pasillos
de los tribunales a los que se enfrentan
las mujeres sospechosas de haber
abortado nos encontramos con Ana Vera
esta abogada es una militante ha
convertido la defensa de estas mujeres
en una de las luchas de su vida en las
oficinas de su asociación surcuna
acumula los expedientes y a veces
denuncia los métodos moralizantes de
algunos jueces la penalización del
aborto también responde si quieres a un
castigo frente al incumplimiento de un
mandato el mandato de la paternidad no y
de Cómo ser madre de aceptar los hijos
que Dios quiera cuando Dios los quiera
aunque no tengas las condiciones yo tuve
un caso de una niña indígena que se
había provocado un aborto Pues decidió
que tenía que ir a un orfelinato para
que desarrolle el instinto materno no
Entonces tienes todo este prejuicio ahí
combinado como que las mujeres que
abortan fueran monstruos si quieres
patológicos
ha visto los magistrados condenar a las
mujeres Aunque el expediente de
acusación estuviera falsificado
yo he visto cosas terribles como
modificación de autopsias lo cual es un
delito que porque es fraude pero se sale
cambio de documentos he visto mujeres
condenadas con una página bajada del
internet contando lo que es un
medicamento sin ninguna prueba real
porque el objetivo es encarcelarlas
declararlas culpables aún cuando no hay
evidencia no
penalizadas con o sin pruebas
entre las mujeres que han ido a prisión
por aborto muy pocas aceptan contar su
historia la mayoría sienten vergüenza y
temen ser señaladas
hoy Ana vino a visitar a Soraya hace
cinco años la abogada la defendió
todo comenzó cuando unos fuertes dolores
en el vientre la despertaron en medio de
la noche y sentí que me sonaba me sonaba
así la barriga cuando como que algo se
me bajó así de una
y así se me desprendió
y yo me regresé a ver así y yo y yo vi
un bebé
Entonces yo le yo cogí y le saqué así de
ahí y yo le y yo le empezaba a hacerle
así a golpearle así la espalda hacia
aplastarle
[Música]
Soraya no sabía que estaba embarazada su
bebé no sobrevivió se desmayó y se
despertó en el hospital los policías y
el médico empezaron a interrogarlo ahí
me dijo tú tomaste pastillas el día de
ayer algo ya dije no O sea ellos
trataban de quererme confundirme y sacar
mi información entonces por eso le dije
no doctor y yo le digo que yo tomé esa
agua de orégano pero yo no fue por
abortarle porque yo ni sabía lo que
estaba así lo que estaba embarazada al
otro día llegó a vuelta el fiscal y
otros dos más llegaron ahí y ahí dijo el
fiscal dijo a ver a ver señora Mejía
dijo
Usted dijo tal vez lo cometió dijo de
Natalia al bebé porque era un hijo de su
compañero de trabajo
ya le dije pero si yo trabajaba siempre
con mis hermanos y yo no he dicho le
dije eso
encontrar un motivo es lo que buscan Los
investigadores que parten del principio
de que hubo un aborto después de dos
días en el hospital Soraya fue
transferida a la cárcel al otro día
cuando yo me levanté me hice así y hoy
había estado sangrando desde la espalda
bastantísimo era pero una hemorragia
fatal
votaba bastantísima sangre por las que
me yo me daba vergüenza que yo cerraba
las piernas y de ahí el chico me acuerdo
que dijo yo ya había salido en libertad
si se muere la señora y yo le yo les voy
a ser responsable dijo por la vida de la
señora porque yo la estoy viendo cómo
está a las 24 horas finalmente fue
atendida pero La pesadilla continuaba el
fiscal llegó incluso a procesarla por
homicidio basándose en una demostración
cuestionable
lo que pasa es que abren al bebé cogen
el pulmón y lo meten en agua si el
pulmón flota se supone que respiro y
entonces ahí las acusan por asesinato si
el pulmón se hunde no respiro Entonces
es aborto viste el tema es que el pulmón
puede flotar por muchas otras cosas más
y tenemos como múltiples expertos
internacionales que dicen que esto es
una prueba que no debería poder
considerarse Si quieres al menos en
procesos penales por la gran cantidad de
falsos positivos que dan yo me quedaba
solita y yo lloraba
lloraba mucho y
lo único que yo quería es salir salir de
aquí ya cuando voy a salir de aquí yo me
pasaba solo lo más llorando
tras seis meses de cárcel Ana Vera
consiguió la absolución Soraya no aborto
ni mató a su bebé
rápidamente volvió a quedar embarazada
fue gracias a Daniela su hija que pudo
superar el dolor de esa injusticia
Da gracias a Dios mamita dice que tú me
tienes a tu lado yo soy tu compañía mamá
[Música]
la historia de Soraya no habría sido más
que un drama privado si un médico no la
hubiera denunciado tres cuartas partes
de las mujeres viven una situación
similar porque incluso dentro de los
hospitales públicos los médicos deciden
notificar a la policía
en Quito Virginia Gómez médica milita
desde hace años por el derecho al aborto
ha visto cómo se ha difundido la actitud
de sospecha ante las pacientes que
tienen abortos espontáneos cuando las
mujeres Llegan ya con una complicación
han pasado varios días el medicamento ya
no está en el cuerpo Entonces como así
las denuncian eso tiene mucho que ver
con una posición religiosa en este punto
los médicos son muy religiosos sea de la
Iglesia Católica o sea de la iglesia
evangélica que está muy activos en
contra de los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos
desde que comenzó la criminalización del
aborto Virginia ha comprobado que la
situación es muy preocupante como
feministas como mujeres y también como
médicas sentimos indignación porque
vemos que el poder del Médico o de la
clase médica o de la clase profesional
de la salud es misógino odia a las
mujeres des patriarcal es machista dando
un mensaje a las mujeres ojo si ustedes
se hacen un aborto yo les denuncio yo
les puedo enjuiciar y les puedo
encarcelar el mensaje no es solo para
esa mujer el mensaje es para todas
a pesar del riesgo algunas no tienen
otra opción más que acudir de urgencia a
los hospitales públicos en esta sala de
maternidad de la capital casi todos los
meses José masache ginecólogo se hace
cargo de las mujeres que han abortado y
que sufren complicaciones
el no entiende a quienes actúan como
sustitutos de la policía
el médico no está
facultado para hacer la denuncia porque
estaba faltando contra el secreto
profesional Y esto es más grave que la
denuncia aquí tan solo en 2019 400
mujeres fueron recibidas después de un
aborto
algunas pasaron por consultorios
clandestinos Porque después de tres
meses de embarazo una pastilla no es
suficiente
puede haber infecciones puede haber
sangrado
puede haber
perforaciones uterinas esto lleva a
enfermedades o a pérdida de la
fertilidad inclusive pérdida de el útero
independientemente de cuál haya sido la
razón del aborto no tenemos nosotros que
preguntar nada simplemente cumplir
nuestro trabajo que es el salvar la
salud y la vida de estas mujeres
las mujeres suelen abortar a escondidas
y en secreto si ni siquiera contárselo a
su familia
hace dos años Sergio estaban lejos de
imaginarse lo que estaba viviendo su
hermana
me llamo igual a una una amiguita que
tengo que trabaja ahí en el hospital a
decir que que tenía que ser camello de
urgencia porque mi hermana estaba súper
mal
llegué al hospital en lo que habían
hecho ellos es destripar el útero para
para tratar de parar la hemorragia que
ella tenía
Entonces yo le pregunté al doctor Pero
que qué qué pasó entonces me dijo que
era un aborto clandestino
tenía tres perforaciones uterinas
transcurrió Ya siquiera unos 45 minutos
entonces golpeó la puerta de ahí del
área de terapia intensiva y salió el
doctor y me hicieron pasar y y me
dijeron que
que que la sentía mucho
que había muerto
[Música]
Guadalupe tenía 34 años Vivía sola con
sus dos hijos
[Música]
mi hermana mi sobrino y mi sobrina Bueno
al inicio no asimilaban pensaban que
iba a regresar
y mis sobrinos quedan en la orfanadas O
sea no hay no hay nadie quien le que le
que le apoye e incluso dejaron de
estudiar por un tiempo hasta ver cómo
nos organizamos tuvimos que pagarles
psicológico psicólogos porque les afectó
mucho la familia presentó una denuncia
contra el médico que practicó el aborto
de su hermana pero a pesar de las
pruebas y de testimonios contundentes
fue absuelto durante el juicio Sergio
también descubrió que mientras su
hermana agonizaba un médico del hospital
la había denunciado nos encontramos con
la sorpresa que que la demanda estaba en
contra de mi hermana o sea porque ella
se practica un aborto porque estará una
persona muerta está está acusada cuando
el verdadero culpable seguían las calles
eso sería la solución O sea que sea
despenalizado el aborto si no siempre
van a estar acudiendo a las a estos
consultorios clandestinos y iban a
seguir ocurriendo hasta estas muertes
la historia de Guadalupe no es una
excepción
según los datos oficiales cada año
alrededor de 30 mujeres corren la misma
suerte
[Música]
una cifra sin duda subvalorada porque
muchas mueren antes de poder acceder a
los servicios de salud
[Música]
a 30 kilómetros de allí el grupo provida
llega a la iglesia Santa Rosa para una
ceremonia muy particular
la directora de la fundación Amparo
Medina está a cargo una vez más
acompañada de sus voluntarios
esa es una adopción espiritual de los
padres y los padres adoptivos pues les
ponen nombres a los bebés
padres y un nombre para cada ataúd
vienen directamente desde la morgue de
la Policía Nacional de Quito
dentro están los fetos de mujeres que
han abortado
[Música]
sí
estos católicos acudieron desde varias
ciudades del país para convertirse en
sus padres simbólicos y hacerles un
funeral
[Música]
[Aplausos]
volvemos a dar dignidad a seres
indefensos que no tuvieron la
oportunidad
de nacer
de crecer tus padres
de desarrollar su vocación y su misión
puedes levantar tu mano derecha y
dirigirla hacia estos féretros
padre clementísimo
en tus manos
encomendamos el alma de estos niños
[Música]
oficialmente Ecuador Es un estado laico
sin embargo estos católicos organizaron
el entierro de 17 fetos con la
colaboración del Ministerio Público y de
la Policía Nacional
hemos tratado por muchos métodos de
llegar a sus familiares y poderles hacer
la entrega de estos bebitos
lastimosamente no hemos podido pero
Hemos llegado hasta el día de hoy hasta
esta ceremonia en la que por fin estos
bebitos van a tener un destino como el
que nosotros hemos querido desde hace
mucho tiempo
[Música]
papitos de Mercedes por favor
José Agustín
[Música]
siento demasiado dolor porque son bebés
que son seres humanos como nosotros
siento un hijo que pude haber tenido que
hubiera querido darle todo el amor del
mundo y no entiendo Pero me imagino que
la presión de que la gente ahora
deshumaniza un bebé Y dice que no es más
que unas células
y es lo que les lleva a tomar esa
decisión pero no es verdad es un bebé es
una persona que siente que no pudo no
pudo ser escuchado sus gritos en el
vientre de su madre que lo matan de una
manera más de la más cobarde
a través de este tipo de actos que se
organizan en varias ciudades del país
Amparo Medina lucha contra lo que ella
califica como cultura de la muerte y en
su explicación lleva muy lejos las
comparaciones
esta visión de ver a los seres humanos
como algo que hay que eliminar por
diferentes circunstancias nos devuelve
la Segunda Guerra Mundial en donde hay
gente que se cree superior a la otra y
que puede matar y dándole cualquier
explicación dándole cualquier
significado porque es negro porque es
blanco porque es judío porque es fruto
de violación porque es pobre porque no
no estoy en la edad porque quiero
estudiar entonces todo aquel que no esté
dentro de mi expectativa tiene que ser
eliminado los problemas hay que
superarlos
las dificultades hay que superarlas
entonces yo no puedo dejarle a una
persona como Pobrecita la violada o sea
eso es una estupidez Perdóname la
palabra
aceptar su suerte en Ecuador cada día
cinco niñas menores de 14 años tienen un
bebé producto de una violación
durante años Ana Vera y sus compañeras
salieron a las calles para exigir que
fuera posible aportar en abril de 2021
la corte constitucional falló a su favor
pero rápidamente los diputados
conservadores impusieron plazas
restrictivos entonces Ana Vera Se subió
a la tribuna de la asamblea
es un momento de hacer historia por las
niñas por las mujeres por las personas
que estantes Víctimas de sobrevivientes
de violencia sexual exigimos una ley de
aborto por violación justa y reparadora
poner un plazos lo que hará es
denegalizar la clandestinidad hacer que
las mujeres que tengan más de este caso
tengan que buscar abortos clandestinos
pero el presidente Guillermo lasso
Consideró que esta ley seguía siendo
demasiado permisiva la vetó parcialmente
lo que le permitió fijar sus condiciones
las víctimas de violación no solo
tendrán tres meses para abortar deberán
poner una denuncia o hacerse un examen
médico que demuestre la agresión la ley
que salió de la asamblea fue Aún si
quieres empeorada con el veto ejecutivo
del presidente lazo siempre ha sido una
persona muy conservadora él es parte del
opus Dei es un hombre absolutamente
autoritario que impone sus posturas
personales sobre si quieres los derechos
de la población
[Música]
la lucha de Ana parece estar muy lejos
de terminar en Ecuador en los medios más
Humildes el aborto todavía es un tema
tabú incluso para las mujeres que en
principio tienen derecho a hacerlo
[Música]
a 150 kilómetros de la capital en Santo
Domingo Este hogar de acogida de
hermanas benedictinas se hace cargo de
jóvenes madres enviadas allí por la
justicia
todas quedaron embarazadas después de
una violación algunas tienen
discapacidad mental como Juliette de 15
años llegó aquí con seis meses de
embarazo
[Música]
Ok Quién es él Cómo se llama tu hijo
y Cuántos años tiene David ocho meses
ocho meses
y aquí tenemos
Quién es Sergio
[Música]
papá de David y Cuántos años tiene
Sergio 68
así y él
Qué hizo contigo quién es Es tu amigo no
era tu amigo
[Música]
me tocó
bueno Y cómo te sentiste después de que
este señor te haya tocado
claro es normal sentirse mal
Y qué pasa con David que sientes cuando
ves a David porque producto de lo que él
te tocó
nació David verdad
Y qué sientes con David
bonito
y tú quieres mucho a David no sé
[Música]
su edad mental su desarrollo mental es
eso es de una niña de 7 años es una niña
que está cuidando a otro niño
con discapacidad y víctima de violación
en este caso la ley autoriza el aborto
desde hace prácticamente Un siglo sin
embargo los médicos y la justicia
decidieron por Juliette
nadie topó o se acercó a esa posibilidad
para mí es un poco absurdo que una
persona con discapacidad que logre
decidir sobre su aborto sobre esa
posibilidad de aborto
abortar en el momento puede solucionar
el problema puede ir aliviando ese dolor
fuerte del trauma emocional pero no nos
asegura con el futuro no generó to
trauma que es la culpa
engaños adultos cuando ya logre tener
un análisis de lo sucedido ya lo haya
digerido y Y esa pérdida de ese aborto
genere en ella también un peso
Uy el bebé
no puede entender lo que es un aborto
pero de todas maneras sería capaz de
sentirse culpable
una contradicción que esconde mal una
postura anti aborto
en las zonas altas de quito los
habitantes tienen la costumbre de decir
que la virgen le da la espalda a los
barrios más pobres de la ciudad
[Música]
esos barrios donde las mujeres mueren
donde las niñas crean hijos no deseados
y donde otras son Incluso condenadas en
nombre de la moral
[Música]